foreign
[Music]
we're not there the car exploded
come get the girls I have to stay here
with Woodrow another chauffeur I'm the
grandfather where are you asteroid City
Farm Road 6 Mile 75
your star gazers and Space Cadets each
year we celebrate asteroid day
commemorating September 23rd 3007 BC
when the Arid Plains meteorite made
Earth impact
oh
it can be Toledo that's Mitch Campbell
you're very good in the one about the
[__] in the brothel who gets amnesian
making a pediatrician you're very
honestly maybe my favorite character
ever I don't know why nobody else liked
it
what are those pulses indicate what oh
the beeps and blips we don't know some
of our information about outer space May
no longer be completely accurate anyway
there's still only nine planets in the
solar system as far as we know Billy
except now there's an alien
I don't know I don't like the way that
guy looked at us the alien how did he
look like we're doomed
maybe we are I've just informed the
president how long can they keep us an
asteroid City legally the world will
never be the same that's an alien doing
jumping jacks that's an alien at Top Hat
what's out there the meaning of life
maybe there is one are you married I'm a
widower but don't tell my kids you're
saying her mother died three weeks ago
let's say she's in heaven which doesn't
exist for me of course but you're
Episcopalian in my loneliness I learned
to give complete and unquestioning Faith
to the people I love I don't know if
that includes you but it included my
daughter and your four children
sometimes I think I feel more at home
outside the Earth's atmosphere oh wow
me too they're strange aren't they
they're children
compared to normal people yes that's
correct it's true
going so fast
I do a nude scene you want to see it
did I say yes you didn't say anything I
meant yes my mouth didn't speak
a lot has happened since My Big Fat
Greek Wedding
never left my father passed away and His
Last Wish was for us to visit his
childhood Village and reconnect with our
Roots so we're having a reunion we're
going to Greece oh yeah
[Music]
and by Lee I mean
the whole family who wants souvlucky
paging Souvlaki anybody by the name of
sulaki on his flight
Aristotle what I didn't know you were
going to be here you're doing here they
had an amazing date
she ghosted him
[Music]
we are related through your Papa's Papa
who was married to my great great Yaya
sister sustaino
I learned Bula I will be your favorite
I promised my dad I would find his best
friends I know them do they still live
here no how do we find them they will
come for the reunion did they tell you
they're coming no
there's no other bedrooms family
sleepover this is one reunion
yeah
we'll never forget do you know do you
know man no I am surprised but I am not
surprised because I'm never surprised
you lost me
[Music]
you dreamed about Aristotle last night
how did you know Greek Voodoo bam I
remember your story I really need to
find my dad's friends Angelo and I are
on it okay bye
[Music]
let's do it
I'm calling it you got us back to Greece
you're the head of the family now I
can't really Day drink like this don't
worry a lady is never drunk
pick the one we have for dinner oh thank
you uh I'm a vegetarian
no
[Music]
we got these
today is going to be the best day ever
I love sunshine I love butterflies but
more than anything I love done hey
shut the [__] up
that's Doug the best owner in the world
we're playing this game called fetching
[__] he drops me off really far away
and drives home without me when I bring
the ball back he says that's how I know
I won the game
hey honey you ever been with an Afghan
before I don't know what thank you thank
you for me kid he left your ass oh that
can't be right you are officially astray
that would mean
duck doesn't love me poor little guy I
should probably talk to him I am a
therapy dog
you can learn how beautiful he can be
when you're off the lead this beer is
making me dizzy he's about to get real
Dizzy up in this I'm having a great time
right here
what did you just say for this to get
violence
I'm going back to Doug's what man he
needs to pay for what he did with the
only thing he truly loves I'm oh
wait did he just say yeah I'm still a
little drunk but I said I'm gonna bite
this oh we go
hey today you've ever humped anything
before I wouldn't say a pumped for safe
there you go red I'm doing good tell it
no I'm yours Daddy hey gnome I'm your
father it's good to finally meet you
right even under these strange
circumstances
completely lost and my little puppy paw
pads are really hurting right now so how
exactly could this get worse
shut up
guys we've got it to rip off
what are those kind of looks like food
oh uh give me a second you look
different you look different too how so
is it my human hands
[Music]
the patience has lost the ability to
speak he's not deaf and he's technically
not new with the proper amount of care
it's possible that he could regain his
understanding of the world his ability
to speak what's our first course of
action well the state is not going to
pay for any of that so we are going to
put his ass on the first bus downtown
what do you mean he won't get out of the
trailer
get in
take a look at this guy what about him
he's a dead ringer for you man don't
look nothing like me I mean look at him
he's too short get finished today for
you
caught latte Pronto excuse me Mr Pronto
can I play latte
latte Pronto latte Toronto is that your
name you and me are gonna do big things
pal and respect bro move star's coming
through
welcome to your team you got me your
agent got your manager lawyer publicist
Personal Assistant Plus we've got you an
intern
you have got a big film Premiere
tomorrow night does that make you a
little nervous
this was a gift from Prince Harry it was
one of the original Knights of the Round
Table sword or something I can't really
remember because I wasn't listening when
he gave it to me
make love to me latte
away
I'm comfy as you jump in the phone is
not ringing don't worry bill I'll get
this back on top I know you think what's
been happening to your careers
accidental everything is by Design
who are you really latte pronto
[Music]
and play time
Gotta Get Down big time
for residents of element City
Air usually has their head in the cloud
oh my new jacket Earth can be a little
seedy
nothing weird going on here just a
little pruning water is always getting
into something
[Music]
fire
as ordered we run a little hot
[Music]
this shop is dream of our family someday
it'll all be yours but we all live by
one simple rule
elements cannot mix
pipe squished me all out of shape
that's better oh
so you've never left firetown sorry
buddy elements don't mix
hey plus my dad would boil you alive why
does anyone get to tell you what you can
do in your life come on
why do they even have these yes who
knows
remember I see a change in you
what hair guy you live here it's my
mom's place we got two kids that are
swimming around here somewhere
I've been trying to fill my father's
shoes
never once asked what I wanted to do
write this Dad those are too hot I love
hot food
[Music]
[Applause]
you see he likes it
we all write our own stories there he is
Richard I'd like to speak to him I'm
here
I'm the guy who helped bring the world
the most popular snack it's ever seen
are you ready
I've been ready all right all right it
was a little bit more like this
spicy
yeah see that's how I got here dear God
please forgive me for the gang the drugs
it's on cars what the heck man let's
move it hey he's prank but now go ahead
baby
the guy started at the berry bottom I
know I don't look it but I got a PhD I'm
poor hungry and determined sir okay I
can see you're gonna be a weird one
what's happening well sir Frito-Lay
isn't getting enough orders to keep the
Factory open please Cool Ranch anyway
[Applause]
what is it it burns stop eating it I
like it it was good I had been searching
for an answer
and there it was
they had been there the entire time
you're a good idea it's a spicy kit it's
gonna change everything and we'll save
our Factory and you're a janitor we're
gonna go hang on no one could kill you
figure out the next step see the
Hispanic market will not be ignored the
Hispanic market would not be ignored
good but in your voice
you're wasting time on this janitors
crazy idea guys like you want me we'll
get shots like this you see that guy
right there I see a chingon Montana
get out there and be great
you want to know that we may
if we knew that there was a product out
there for us we'd say take our money
caruniz
I got a little Hood there at the end but
you lost the fire
[Applause]
[Music]
place
good
it's known as the beautiful game but
let's face it it's a complicated game
guys soccer as you like to call it is
like life next season I think we have a
real shot
I'm sorry uh Thomas did nobody tell you
you're you're fired
good news is you got two options option
one that's where you're currently at or
American Samoa are you serious
we haven't scored one goal in the
history of our country trying to have a
soccer team go let's start again
humiliation mark my words things are
going to change I got us a new coach
something to drink whiskey beer wine yep
we got all those which one whiskey beer
and wine
foreign
it's safe to say you have zero Talent OR
understanding of the game
I'm right about the sky what he is white
coach you got the toughest job on the
island
what we want is just one goal one goal
come on guys we've worked too long and
hard for this you've only been here a
few days
I can't work with these guys for them
it's like some sort of game
that's a giant leadership now we're
making some progress
thank you for sending us Mr rongan we've
become quite attached to him it's like
finding a little lost white kid at the
mall and telling him which way to go
[Music]
I can't believe it I just can't believe
it
no can I
feel like I just saw him
yeah he just called me last week
it was a butt dial
what are we gonna do he's actually where
was durfy the happiest easy Harrison is
perfect you know what you think about it
that is where it all began
oh my God it's spring break
[Music]
you remind me my granddad Granddad how
old do you think I am I don't know how
old 40.
oh this son of a [__] straight up stole
our games
oh
oh my God I get her number welcome to
the ultimate game this is our reminder
to be mindful be mindful of history and
her story and they story just kill us
now
[Music]
your chariots went
this is gonna be fun isn't it buddy
these people suck
what will your journey be because once
those are magic mushrooms I just ate 10
of these things come on you got a trip
I'm not taking any mushrooms I'll eat
these pink things though oh
what's up guys
[Music]
we got a mustache why'd you grow your
hair up
One Tap of the tongue is the most
powerful hallucinogen what are you doing
you're welcome sweetheart
Eddie Lynn yoga instructor's in the gym
now
legs on a new shot are you dehydrated
100 bucks you can't make more shots it's
just a 300. it's not my dad's money
[Music]
they're never gonna get a reparation
that way bro so I prefer venmo or Zell
but you seem like a cash app guy so
ladies and gentlemen
you think it's slick huh it's showing up
the course dressed like a dumbass acting
like you can't who you assumed I
couldn't because I'm white which is
incredibly outdated I assumed you
couldn't hoop because you were dressed
like a white girl at Whole Foods
it's really hard to plan for the future
when we're always worried about money
because you're out here living in a
fantasy my 30-day detox program I want a
free sample no I ain't drinking no
boo-boo juice babe it's almost the first
I'm gonna go tomorrow I forgot why don't
you just go now it'll be fine don't
worry mommy don't worry mommy every
Hooper I know is entering that big ass
tournament with a winner get 500 000. I
just need somebody who can play so I can
make some money
be joking right 500 000 for one day I
hope yeah yeah yeah we can hustle a few
games together to get the money for the
entry fee I'll find some marks those
short shorts look incredible throw them
off their game yeah the only fast and
we'll clean up you're gonna wear that
trash bag you can wear that fake ass
Richard Simmons outfit
bro I bet y'all got one coming to music
release for me
you
just wanted to see if you had superhuman
hearing because of your because my wife
they're gonna kill him in the parking
lot I'm out here he got a flamethrower
flamethrower what is this Mad Max
played in today good work thank you you
could talk way more trash out there you
have so much material I can't even touch
like what
never mind oh
tell us where the Love Goes
[Music]
my name's Miles Morales I'm Brooklyn's
one and only Spiderman and things are
going great
he's gonna be here any minute it should
be simple enough give me your money so
are you like a cow or a Dalmatian
Spider-Man
I am the spot
that's not funny
don't do that
there's bubbles now hold on
that's cute right the youth
how's this going nice
grades are pretty good A and AP Physics
that's my little man and a B in Spanish
what okay miles
bye
miles win wanna get out of here
welcome to spider Society
I'm Spiderman oh no way all of us are
me
Miguel O'Hare
O'Hara it's like a ninja vampire
Spider-Man but a good guy plus he's like
such a good leader
there's moments in our stories that are
the same for all of us some good did you
bring our baby to another fight I knew I
was gonna regret making her that web
shooter you asked me not to so I didn't
I wouldn't it's in bed you have a choice
between saving one person and saving
every world to me an obvious choice send
me home I can't do that I can do both
stop Spider-Man
everyone keeps telling me how my story
is supposed to go
nah I'm gonna do my own thing
can this day get weirder
I guess I can
there's nowhere to run
my bad everybody there was somewhere to
run
sorry I wasn't thinking about this game
are you okay yeah
it's my fault let me hook you up I'm
Elaine 10 years ago we created the
robots who now do the tasks Americans
once did Thomas Newton was sentenced to
28 years after he had an illegal robot
double of himself you hear that robot
to be more careful
seagull is different level I'm glad
you've met a nice young lady I need you
completely focused on getting a
horizontal for me put yourself on
de-program now see you too
Charles guy really wants to bang me so
he'll have to take over tomorrow too yes
Elaine just don't want the night to end
I feel the same way two Byron E2 pick up
your phone I've never done this before
one two three
the Elena also has a robot double you
are dating a robot all along you two and
I are running away together don't try to
stop us
don't do it
childish
this is terrible they've completely
stolen our lives I'm gonna have to get a
real job calm them down and we kill them
um two cappuccinos thank you you guys
don't understand they're not going to be
obedient anymore
they're humanizing they're learning to
feel you want to get married immediately
let's go go away to stop our wedding
your disgusting Joyride is over
hey I get to shoot me sorry I couldn't
resist we'll find that I'm shooting you
that's not fair
on the other side
swimming to shore oh my God oh my God
foreign
[Music]
hi Ken
hi Barbie hi Barbie hi Barbie hi Barbie
hi Barbie hi Barbie
hi Ken
goes cruising just as fast as she can
now
[Music]
I thought I might stay over tonight why
because we're girlfriend boyfriend you
do what
I'm actually not sure
[Music]
okay ladies let's do this
[Applause]
[Music]
here I'm coming with you
did you bring your rollerblades
I literally go nowhere without them
[Music]
speech was a little too much speech for
you Ken if I wasn't severely injured I
would beat you off right now Ken I'll
beat you up with you any day Ken anyone
who wants to beat him up has to beat me
off first I will beat both of you off at
the same time
nobody's gonna beat anyone off
[Music]
stop Gary court order for acid seizures
so they're taking my car you and radio
silent on me is that what this is about
my feelings for you were so intense that
I got scared is that true bonjorno
that's my cousin Gary I swear to God
he's my cousin he's my second cousin
there's something seriously wrong with
you
I'm an Uber driver and I don't have a
car I'm gonna lose my house you think I
chose this
look at this need a car date our son
this summer and bring him out of his
shawl before College in exchange will
give you a Buick Regal date is in quotes
sex my husband the code breaker
he's just been so worried about our son
he's going to Princeton in the fall no
I've heard of it you know we tried
everything to bring him out of his shell
he doesn't come out of his room he
doesn't talk to girls and drinks so when
you say date him do you mean date him or
date him yes date him date him hard I'll
date his brains out he volunteers at the
animal shelter
hi mind if I touch your wiener what your
dog
how about I give you a ride home
um this isn't the way to my house the
shortcut you're my hostage but you got
down there something for me
this kid is Undateable have a drink
together he'll have a Long Island Iced
Tea
this is the worst iced tea I've ever had
okay
I don't know what to do I just know my
mom would have wanted me to save the
house I feel like just nervous why don't
you loosen them up you can go skinny
dipping what about sharks been here
jellyfish not the season it's really the
lack of life partner right now okay
I'm just a bit of a romantic he's
actually really sweet the best part
about getting older is not having to
care what people think I'm an adult now
I can make my own decisions that's good
you want to save her save her
come on you're getting out of here you
don't belong here get away from her stay
I can't lose my license
standing six foot two inches
[Applause]
how long they've been doing that yes
three or four games weird right yeah I
can see I hate it
kid hit
where's he going to come to college oh
he's coming to work for us the family
business construction I'm a scout if you
want me to make a few phone calls there
might be a hole here or there some of
those holes have scholarships
20 years ago
ain't gonna be no rematch at the end of
Rocky that's 40 years ago was this
sticks oh this is Danny nice to meet you
yeah I do not like her don't be mean in
front of us you don't know us yet come
to dinner Sunday 12 o'clock dinner at
12. I love it I'll be there
Danielle's from Forest Hills we worked
on a house over there guy in Maserati
yeah but it was yellow no thanks any
more meatballs oh I'll make it some more
oh no no please
he gets on that team everything changes
for him you need to turn down the raw
Rock what I'm excited just let it be his
choice
she broke up with me I'm so surprised
your mom's hysterical because she
doesn't like seeing you like this
getting hurt
[Music]
he'll be okay I just gotta get his mind
off it you know get him back on the
court
hey Danny he's not gonna make that team
if he said like this maybe you could go
bug out with him like the pine trees
line in the winding road Leo what did
you do you humiliated him I'm trying to
save him from a lifetime of humiliation
[Music]
stupid sometimes
I always try to do what I think is best
for you
you know your lucky sticks have family
that cares that much
more sticks I was at a long legs came
out of the shoot that way just kept
growing still growing
really came out of my shoot
Mr branfield welcome
I am
the Russian you will make a very good
assistant no he's evil we will protect
you you have the word of the most
trusted institution on Earth the
Catholic Church
[Music]
ill your sole purpose in life is to
serve me now let's see
I just want to know more life again
God bless you Mr Renfield oh God bless
you nuns you're a hero Robert Montague
Renfield
let me explain I work for Dracula Count
Dracula
it's the real Dracula some call me The
Dark One
others the Lord of death so you bring
and people to eat well I do other stuff
like what washes cake no the Cape is dry
clean only strictly yeah I will wear
this it's fly yeah
we've got nothing such a bad guy but
you're never really gonna be free until
you face him I will no longer tolerate
abuse I deserve happiness
okay you deserve only suffering I will
Unleashed everyone you care about will
suffer because you betrayed me we have
to stop him Before Sunset
[Music]
I
deserve happiness and I take full charge
[Music]
you know when something crazy happens
and someone's like it's okay I've seen
way worse everything I saw you do today
is gonna be my way worse it's my least
favorite part of the job
[Music]
you guys must be new to town right new
to town but not new to the country we
just moved from California oh we just
wondered uh if you wouldn't mind if your
daughter played with our daughter Audrey
say hi
fly
slides off limits to Ching chongs
cute
do you want to be best friends look at
me look at me look at me now guess who's
going back to the motherland it's a big
deal going to your birth country I used
to talk about it all the time when we're
little remember Grand Adventure to find
your birth mother so proud of you
y'all calling me crazy my translator in
Beijing Audrey I got you ready
[Laughter]
Kat lives there now your famous college
roommate you ready to lose to a
celebrity
where did that come from
you know I think I get it I called the
adoption agency and she lives in high
Ching okay will you guys come with me
[__] yes [__] I love a grand Adventure
you're drug dealers now [__] what the
[__] is that a condom we can't get
caught with drugs in China we'll get
jailed for life
never come to China people are always
thinking that I have this perfect life I
don't belong anywhere if you do not know
where you come from how do you know who
you are
still find her our passports are in my
suitcase that got stolen you know we can
bypass the airport security K-pop Stars
everyone remember their names sassy
cutie Lisa Lisa too I don't believe
these girls girls
[Music]
is she here
there's some [__] in this house
there's some horse
did you get the coke bags out yeah but
only seven and I think I put an eight
just push pull I mean it's not a puppet
it's my [__]
foreign
gifted where are you I'm in a church
what are you serious we're looking for a
venue for the wedding you're going to
get married in a church I'm shocked you
didn't burst into flames as you cross
the threshold
to live in Arthur oh thank you I think
we should all go to Italy Italy whoa
we'll make it bib's Bachelorette a
bachelorette trip what are we doing I
think it's very romantic but it's also
nuts
[Music]
I'm delighted that you'll be joining us
tonight there's no problem with four
random women show up this is Italy
there's always room for random beautiful
women Gianni who is Tiana what are you
doing here this is my cookie School wow
and here to start the animals Bush I
think somebody's bush is already quite
amused
Bridal it's not Bridal enough gorgeous
someone else next
move what are you doing that would be me
we're best friends for 50 years and you
married marriage my solo act is finally
coming to a close you're the bravest
person I know the only question is how
will we mess this all up I can't wait to
find out
is it too soon to talk about who we're
gonna eat first I think we all know hey
how does a woman in her 70s end up
getting married
she takes control of her own destiny
this is the bachelorette party you know
what that means
what a call here where do I stuff the
dollar bills
what do you want to be going to lourd
for anyway I always wanted to go there
where are you Chrissy my mother is dead
I'm in a place I swore I would never
come back to I I wouldn't have
recognized you 40 years we'll do that do
you I'd say yeah mixed
I'm just gonna help us if we go to
lyrics miracles happen there I could
speak
[Music]
welcome to Lord
we're ready I'm not
[Music]
why did you leave leave I was banished I
leave
I loved you and you left uncle had you
came home can you ever forgive me
[Music]
you don't come to Lewis for a miracle
Island you come to the strength to go on
when there is no America
and there's always hope peace that's
what I hope for
a devoted wife and mother a doting
grandmother Joyce was a wonderful woman
this is Claire one of Joyce's oldest
friends ever College together Howard
I'm gonna kill you now that she's gone
we're gonna do it this weekend
[Music]
to you about what I told him I was gonna
kill him
I could chat it's been four and a half
decades feels like it was yesterday you
were delusional she told me you were
cruel
so what's the plan Scarface I'm gonna
buy a gun it was cute very wanna hold it
and I'm gonna take it to the wake
how's the recoil hey coil not gonna lie
it has a little kick well darn it we
tried do you have any poison I have a
cyanide pill in case I'm captured by the
enemy you can have it
[Applause]
I want you to tell the truth I am
shocked by your utter selfishness you
blame me for what happened in your own
marriage I think you were not built for
happiness I'm in you're in what my other
murder canceled this week so I've got
time I've missed you you've had my
number well you had my number so we're
both lousy friends
[Music]
oh Christ God
[Applause]
[Music]
why are you carrying that knife oh I was
gonna stab someone
who is it it's Ralph I slept with him
last night you have a condom I don't
want to get Knocked Up
I'm Ria Khan I am going to be a stock
woman
[Music]
my sister Lina is the only person who
believes in me want to help me with a
vid for my Channel please
she helped me with all my training you
are going to be such a great stumbler
that was Doppler but lately she's been
seeing this guy who I think is a bit of
a smarmy wanker
you know it's a truck oh my God Ria
chill out now I'm not being dramatic
but these people are evil
I found something
they are not taking her away without a
fight
I will strike down you or anyone else
who tries to get in my way
how about the bikini area
Let's Dance
we need to get Lena out
how Mischief is a foot
Nina's not going anywhere
[Music]
nothing changes
we are going to show Lena who these
people really are
calling me crazy
[Applause]
did you see my kick of course I bloodied
it it was magical
I'm sure I drew blood
my parents are inviting us to the Summer
Place for the big Fourth of July weekend
I can't leave my father this is the
first summer since we have to say
goodbye to you dear Mother and you're
going to leave me to burn the spot
because alone why don't we just bring
him nah I don't think so you hear this
ladies he's worried his immigrada's
gonna make it look like some kind of
Goomba all right listen if we're gonna
do this Dad you gotta dial it down
what is this walking away wow this is
amazing
[Music]
it's called love and affection man
unlike you when you met me at the
delivery room you chose to shake my hand
what else was I supposed to do we just
met
Sebastian I don't know how you're gonna
fit in waiters
don't these people have jobs they got
their money in the stock market that
mayonnaise jars buried in their backyard
I just hope nothing gets stolen this
weekend because these people love to
blame the immigrants
we'll give you the grand tour this is
Doug he's learning to be a Healer hello
what are you doing just serenading our
pet peacock
foreign
[Music]
I was nervous to bring you here but I
didn't know you're gonna spend the whole
time embarrassing me how could you say
that to your father Here We Go Again
everything I'm doing for you that I've
ever done for you is for your own good
hey man check it out I died
I'm trying to make sure that you don't
make an ass out of yourself by trying to
be somebody you're not
oh
I would love to make a full Italian
dinner for everybody we don't keep a lot
of food here Amanda scalco always finds
a way to feed his family
my father has an old Italian saying
family isn't one important thing it's
everything I can't believe you put this
all together from what we have in the
kitchen it's not a joke and poultry
[Music]
oh no
oh
give a little bit you slide up their pet
peeve packed and you thought I was crazy
for worrying that you were gonna make us
look like some bad Italian staff that's
right to help me get rid of the evidence
why does it seem like you've done this
before
[Music]